Counter-Strike has always had a ton of
weapons for players to choose from
arguably too many to the point where
nobody really uses most of them in csgo
you had to be Discerning about which
weapons to include in your Loadout which
meant that some were just always left
out but CS2 has attempted to change all
of that guns that were previously pushed
to the side are now available to use in
Your Arsenal players now create a load
out of weapons to bring into the match
five pistols five mid tier weapons and
five rifles this means that for the
first time ever you can equip the M4 A4
and the M4 a1s in the same match then
some other pistols what do I want to
have a desert eagle of course now the
question is can I equip R8 and Desert
Eagle at the same
time yes we can but has CS 2's weapon
Loadout system improved the game in a
way that valve hoped or are certain
weapons still being left behind and is
this new approach actually hurting the
[Applause]
game all right so before we get into
cs2s Loadout system I want to remind you
all that we have merch head to shop.
thescore.com to check it out okay so CS2
has changed Counterstrike in a number of
ways some good some not so good but back
when the game first launched one of the
most exciting new features was the
loadout system in csgo you had to pick a
different weapon for each section of
your Loadout based on your play style or
your role within your team you'd select
certain guns to help you get through any
scenario you might face the problem was
that players had to choose between some
crucial weapons like the M4 A4 and the
M4 a1s you couldn't equip both of them
and because of this certain guns rarely
saw use and if they did it was usually
for the
memes yeah oh my God double kill triple
oh my God but in CS2 you get to pick
five pistols five mid-tier weapons and
five rifles which is a pretty big deal
most notably you can now equip both the
M4 a1s and the M4 A4 or if you're a
weirdo you can equip an R8 alongside
your deagle this is something that
players begged for for years nobody
wanted to be restricted to one of these
guns for an entire match and giving
players the option to equip both in
their Loadout would provide more
versatility in different situations the
M4 A4 was great for taking down targets
from close to mid-range while the M4 a1s
excelled at long range engagements due
to its increased accuracy the argument
in favor of using both grew even
stronger as the A4 and a1s started
seeing pretty similar use near the end
of CSG Go's lifespan we even made a
video about the a1s specifically in late
2022 after it started seeing more and
more play but as I said at the start
csgo had arguably too many weapons to
choose from some of them like the M2 49
were literally never used and if they
ever were it was either the result of a
misclick or some BM and what did P just
buy is that a that must have been a
mistake he just bought the the
M249 I don't even understand I just want
to see we have to see this just uh
carrian with the awp and here we go pip
they are going to smoke out and Flash
out he's going to run out with his back
turn down to 1 HP it's going to his and
although underutilized weapons like the
M249 were just never seen in Pro play
valve couldn't just up and remove them
from the game a big reason for that was
that plenty of players had loads of
skins for them and everyone wanted those
skins to transfer over to the new game
so when trailers for CS2 started rolling
out and valve unveiled their new Loadout
system players were pumped to jump into
the Limited Test it's cool this is way
more like modern like this style of
loadouts is way more modern this is cool
so I I could be like you know what I
don't want dues I'm going to put
on uh a Cy and a teken that's neat CS2
seriously streamlined the weapon Loadout
system and made it way more digestible
for newer players now you could just
pick and choose whatever guns you wanted
to use throughout a match ingame valve
also removed the old by wheel that
allowed you to click on each category of
gun and replaced it with a valerant
esque menu that shows you all your guns
at once to the ogs it might even remind
you of the Cs 1.6 by menu but most
importantly you could finally refund
weapons if you accidentally purchased
the wrong one but these new features
weren't just interesting because they
made CS2 more accessible for new players
they were interesting because they had
the potential to change Counterstrike
completely can choose up to five of each
class to bring into a game say for
example now I have the MP9 but the game
went [__] and I realized I don't like
the MP9 then I can change it out for for
example a ump and then in the next match
I'll be able to buy the UMP but not the
MP9 of course this also brings some uh
interesting new features to CS I can
actually have both of the m4s an M4 a1s
and the M4 A4 same for pistols I can now
have a desert eagle but if I want to I
could also equip an R8 revolver so you
have more customizability with your load
out but you're also restricted by the
fact that you can only bring five of
each type also just preparing for CS2
you know definitely going to have A4 and
silencer in the load out I I think when
you're CT you're playing against like
antios you know they have pistols A4 is
going to be way more Superior cuz you
have a bigger chance just to you know
mow down like five people without
armors silary less bullets let's speak
of a chance but you can still do it and
when CS2 officially launched players
finally got exactly what they wanted
mainly the ability to run both m4s
everyone was excited that they could
finally swap between the two throughout
a match but despite all of the changes
to the rest of the game play the gun
meta remains relatively unchanged
compared to CS goo's and maybe it's
because of how the categories of weapons
are assembled over time players have
grown concerned that perhaps cs2s weapon
Loadout system is actually worse than
its predecessors and in some ways
punishing exploration and Innovation
some believe that will never see
situations where players suddenly
discover secret overpowered weapons like
what happened with the AUG back in 2019
because each player's Arsenal is just so
limited now and in CS2 the lack of
variety feels particularly bad when it
comes to mid-tier weapons short guns
SMGs and heavy weapons have now all been
combined into the same category which
means there's 11 different weapons in
this uh category but you can only equip
five so if you want the shotgun are you
sure you want to take a shotgun instead
of for example an MP7 or an MP9 well you
don't know I think this mid tier class
is going to be where most of the
customization is now you could argue
that CS 2's Loadout change primarily
hurts casual players since they're more
likely to equip troll picks and purchase
weaker weapons just for the fun of it
but how has this affected Pro play has
it made any real impact on the meta at
the highest level to answer that
question here is Colton to help break
down on some of the data because God
knows I need a break and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
hello Internet it's your favorite nerd
back again talking about uh
Counter-Strike but more importantly
stats okay maybe your third favorite
nerd look I'll settle for fifth all
right so CS2 is still in its infancy the
game's not even 6 months old yet and
it's only had a handful of major lands
most of which came at the end of 2023
but now that propl has switched over to
the new new game it's become clear that
not much has actually changed despite
being able to use both m4s in a single
match players have stuck with the
silenced version in nearly every
situation as we do see Emma make his way
through I think blade might have done
enough here looking for the triple kill
and he's back baby the in-game leader
might have just guaranteed ancient at
the blast Premier World final the M4 a1s
made up
19.76% of all weapon purchases while the
M4 A4 only accounted for 4 .9% that is a
slight Improvement compared to the final
big event for csgo where the M4 A4 only
made up
4.33% of all weapon purchases but when
we look at all the large events since
the end of csgo not a big sample size
I'm aware this change is essentially
negligible add in some lower tier events
and yep same Trend what about the last
year at all levels the A4 has been on a
steady decline for over a year now for
comparison the A4 is being picked at a
similar SAR rate to the Galil unless
valve makes some noticeable changes in
CS2 this trend is likely to continue
valve finally listened to the community
and gave them the option to equip both
m4s but that really hasn't had any
effect on Pro play at least not yet when
there's money and trophies on the line
players are always going to use what
they feel is best and over the past
couple of years that's pretty clearly
been the silenced M4 the good thing is
that if valve ever does decide to Nerf
the a1s again then the M4 a 4 will
already be there ready to go in your
load out especially since most people
are ditching the Famas now anyways and
that was the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about so has cs2s Loadout
change worked yes and no sure players
are opting to equip some of the weapons
that they didn't have available to them
in csgo even though they might not
actually use them in the new game but
the problem still lies with the Casual
player base in that they're now much
more limited lied when it comes to
weapon variety a lot of us were hoping
that maybe just maybe CS2 might launch
with a new weapon or two Counter-Strike
is a game where players have
historically stuck with the same old
guns over and over and rarely touched
anything else and in CS2 that lack of
willingness to explore has unfortunately
gotten even worse outside of troll picks
or Fringe favorites it does sort of seem
like for the time being at least we may
just never see certain guns used
in
CS2 that's like my hottest CS take
actually is that the Scout like needs a
Nerf people are like raise their
eyebrows when I say that but that gun is
it does 70 damage to the body through
armor and it costs $1,700 or whatever it
is it's it's insane you don't even have
to kill them you just have to hit them
in the body they're already out of the
round what are you going to do with an
AK and 29 health